[Musique]
pas de grain de sable sur la plage
d'agnès aujourd'hui mais beaucoup de
grains de beauté la beauté d'isabelle
adjani qui entre deux représentations de
sa pièce
opening night au bout du nord s'offrent
sur la croisette une petite récré
bonjour isabelle je passais devant
l'hôtel et je lis je suis ce que je suis
ce que je suis n'a pas besoin d' excuse
c'est vous qui l'avez dit c'est moins
qu'il ait dit je dois pas être la seule
non c'est un manifeste
c'est vrai que c'est un manifesto
l'aurait alors passé devenu ça mais les
deux vous celui ci oui parce que le leur
c'est parce que je le vaux bien mais on
aime bien ne pas avoir besoin de
s'excuser
c'est essentiel mais c'est quelque chose
qu'on apprend en grandissant
ce qui ne veut pas dire s'est imposé en
verre et surtout contre tous mais ça
veut dire juste être être soit 100 sans
avoir besoin d'expliquer quoi que ce
soit voilà ça je crois que la période
est révolue
oui voilà je suis comme ça parce que ben
non je suis comme ça toi voilà on aime
bien
hier encore vous étiez au théâtre aux
bouffes du nord dû jouer demain il me
semble oui c'est vraiment une parenthèse
cannoise c'est un peu une un mirage
c'est là les limites de l'hallucination
même c'est à dire un aller-retour de
passés de l'obscurité comme celle de la
scène à la
à luminosité d'une croisette en plein
feu d'artifice c'est ça aussi gagner ou
plurielle et au pluriel absolument oui
ça peut être le théâtre de grandes
violences comme de paillettes comme de
cannes c'est un peu ça c'est là la
politique du lieu enfin et c'est le lieu
de cette politique au 6 mai mais ça a
son charme si on aime le décadent et
tutti quanti voilà est-ce que ce
personnage vous quitte quand vous venez
à cannes que vous interprétez de
remplissage unique jamais parce que en
fait c'est s'est elle est là hélas non
les lames et comme elle est déjà doubler
tripler quadrupler quintuple non je n'ai
on est tous venus ensemble avec
lightning qui vous revient du texte un
peu de façon permanente ou récurrente
détends-toi séparée elle c'est une
hallucination et c'est juste c'est du
délire voilà ce que on est au bon
endroit
est ce qu'il ya un film particulièrement
une projection dans cette salle lumière
qui vous revient en tête lorsque j'étais
président du jury 97 que je devais voir
très tôt le matin donc ça c'est quand
même une émotion particulière de de voir
les films à des heures qui sont pas
habituelles et de ressentir de les
ressentir autrement surtout dans cette
salle et puis sinon les moments
d'émotion avec eux patrice chéreau par
exemple pour la reine margot ou d'autres
enfin ces sources 67 des moments qui
sont tellement fort qu'on est un peu
dans le dédoublement
si on est là et en même temps on est
tellement intensément là qu'on se
souvient à peine d'avoir été là c'est
presque une amnésie émotionnelle qui
s'ensuit donc je me souviens de choses
dont je ne me souviens plus très bien en
fait oui ce qui était un petit peu
cannes aussi quand on quitte cannes
on peut être en un petit pas mais
hésitent peut-être de ces deux semaines
qu'on vient de passer à cannes au bout
d'une journée
peut-être oui c'est tout et si si fort
et si parfois vides aussi et si
étrangement décalé en même temps comme
disait godard c'est la marge qui relie
les pages donc on est tous ensemble on
sent une espèce de banc qui peut être
une forme de bouillon de culture parfois
ou alors un bouillon sans culture quoi
enfin le parce que oui pour l'émission
aux jours des petites saynètes où on
reprend des scènes cultes de films
nous ne sommes pas acteur mais ce que je
peux avoir un petit conseil ce qui est
drôle c'est juste la vérité comme ça qui
est un peu qu'ils que maladroite
voila voila je pense qu'inconsciemment
ça fait réflexion sur la comédie ouais
merci isabelle je me sens pris un mini
bain de sang
[Musique]